- okay say hello - Tina tejana her hm  challenge Ponta Negra cartina episode  carne asada arabic hadiya gente aquí la  cámara yes barca state the challenges hi  Ella  [Applause]  I'm a bit scared this first one to break  eye contact loses I'm ready  Zehra Zehra  [Music]  [Music]  come on  [Music]  [Music]  let's try the roger federer show of  table tennis pathetic  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  roger federer I think this challenge is  perfect for me  [Music]  boom come on  who  on backpack one  a lot of you watching are still not  subscribed to our channel so remember  subscribe right here  [Music]  Oh  how to roar okay so we're gonna try and  break this the table thing smile  [Applause]  [Music]  it's not gonna break is it it's gonna  break if water hits  [Music]  [Music]  thank for watching guys make sure to  subscribe to our channel here so you  don't miss out on the next episode until  next time